on March fifth 2012 film courage calm
had the opportunity to attend a press
roundtable interview with salmon Fishing
in the Yemen screenwriter Simon Beaufoy
this audio is an excerpt of that press
day for more information on the film
please visit Fishing in the Yemen com I
like this you can really teasing up I
think what he was we discussing us or
some of the figure theme good teams
involved in the book he said the book
was more of a political satire in return
you turn it into something a little more
timeless can you talk about that yes at
our dates very quickly isn't it and it
was a very it was a sort of biting angry
response to the Tony Blair years of spin
really where things were created out of
nothing just for the price of victory um
and that dated very quickly it's amazing
Brittenham Tony Blair and his years were
forgotten immediately he disappeared and
he was in power for ages I mean and
satire does that it's very relevant and
it's it's a cheese precisely because
it's absolutely in the moment and that
worried me a lot and also it's got a
very because it's got such a hard edge
it's very difficult balance to have SAT
her hand a romantic story in the same
film the to sort of work against each
other the turn of satire is very
unforgiving whereas the terrible
romantic comedy is obviously quite soft
edged so it was quite hard for me to to
work out the tone and and the only way i
could see doing it was was to the lesson
of the satyr really because otherwise it
just kills a remote romantic comedy of
debt not necessarily comedy but earlier
money with her to keep a light touch to
the whole story it's hard because of the
SAT i was yeah yeah and again that was a
case of just distancing it also
certainly for people in britain
distancing it from the real people
which is why i turn the press secretary
into a woman rubbing in the book it's a
man who's clearly based on a sort of
Peter Mandelson type character but uh I
thought it was just a bit too easy in a
bit look funny enough I row the full
monty about the thatcher AZ multimer
came out we've been to changes of
government and it was a it was a sort of
different it was a different air
altogether so you have to be very
careful with satire and films because it
dates so fast advanced you would you be
good at I'm late interesting very
brilliant performance brilliant funds I
mean led you to like the whole the way
they handled her well in the end I think
it was the only way you could make film
that I was was to turn her into an
empathetic character by making her very
fragile and vulnerable on the other hand
I grew up in the industrial north were
was very little empathy around about her
and we never saw nobody ever saw that in
her at all we're and nuts will probably
made her one of the great leaders of the
20th century's that she had very little
compassion for people and what they were
going through and for individuals she
was sort of an ideologist so I was sort
of conflicted about it fixed the
screenwriter moves saying this is very
clever what they've done this isn't
possibly the only way you can make a
film about this woman that people will
want to watch because you actually do
feel for her because she's a fragile
human being at the end of her life the
other half of me was gay sure but what
about what about one's a Sheffield great
sins and you know the stroke of a pen
she destroyed her a huge wave of British
working culture when she turned that to
the whole country through away from me
an industrially common economy into a
service economy I mean many people would
argue that was going to happen anyway
that comes done with great brutality
so that's a long long answer to your
question conflicted is my one word
answer so I think you've ever felt
you've written great sup obviously won
the Oscar for marty is amazingly
hilarious but I gotta wonder the kind of
satisfaction that comes along with
seeing Kristin Scott Thomas deliver some
of the lies that you wrote for her well
I see any time in my life I've actually
written for somebody cuz in it I learned
early on in my life 50 you write write
this for Robert De Niro guess what he's
busy and it doesn't want to come to
Yorkshire for three weeks and no money
so I learned never to write for people
but that was the one part when I made
the decision to make a woman oh I really
really want her to do it because she can
be absolutely terrifying and I wanted
somebody terrifying so uh I think she's
very funny the line where she would when
she's young her kid I mean really that's
one of your from the low right
the owner Rises yeah ya know what he can
imagine I had a lot of fun writing that
think about crystal cut crystal glass
accent laying there sort of things yeah
was there anything kind of book that you
really wanted to keep that you couldn't
oh gosh is that there are certain little
story lines that are now I never really
think about look at it adaptations like
that actually um I'm just you asking
that may be realized the main thing to
keep which i think is sacrosanct is is
the tone and the spirit of the book the
sort of heart of it um I'm when I'm
adapting Pablo was to say to the author
everything's going to change but I
promise you that will keep the spirit in
the heart of your book the same so it
will feel the same to an audience
hopefully I mean that's that's the bit I
feel is absolutely my duty to keep
everything else I'm afraid is up for
grabs because it's
such a different medium that you have to
be quite brutal with the things that
happen the characters and the heart of
the book this tone in the spirit I feel
you need to remain the same sorry I'm
good you talk about your master or other
patients with you that radiance yeah
Master adaptation amenia so yeah I think
it's mo betta screenwriter you know
right original but Yuri good other
application to and which one is a more
pressure which one is more can you feel
like being yourself and and do you want
to go back to my original screenplay
yeah I i I'm going to go back to Russia
original screen take just a little bit
scared that I can't do it anymore
without someone else having a really
good idea and turning into a book um
alright god that's an idea no I I think
strangely my adaptations of work because
of being very brutal with adapting them
but as I say hung on to what I thought
was the most important thing about the
book though Slumdog Millionaire is a
very free adaptation of the book QA and
this is fairly i mean i'd take some
quite mage liberties with salmon fishing
and i bring back one of the characters
from the dead Robert dies very early on
in the book the marine which gave me
great problems or so adaptation because
you know well if this is effectively a
love triangle otherwise wants to stop
attractive Emily of getting together
with attractive viewing you and on page
35 in the book is actually nothing that
stands in their way and sort of all
right in the book but in a film where
you've got two people gradually fall in
love with each other you quickly lock
yourself into a genre where people go
and
get together and and suddenly I my film
sort of stopped around halfway so I had
to keep Robert alive if you know in
order to keep people examining the
possibility and the problems of these
two people getting together so uh I
guess my approach to adapting books is
to treat them with a deep respect on one
level one at another level okay pardon
to one side and go I'm doing something
completely different here can you still
do that with your current adaptation as
i know that's a very good question no ah
and interestingly which i thought was
going to be a problem and it isn't
actually because you are we talking
about catching fire well yell suzanne
collins used to be a TV writer so
actually she done quite off the word for
me already no he's the one time I've not
read the book twice no point one side
which i do with the more I never go I
never go back to them once I've read
them a couple of times with this one I
had to be a lot more faith also because
there's a fan base who are more than
usually keen that you get it absolutely
right and they they have a Hunger Games
fan base Oh passionate beyond anything
I've ever taught us and I would fear for
my life if I get that adaptation if I do
it to free navigator that I shall get
fire bond and so I'm being very careful
about also because Suzanne de has been a
film lighter a TV writer she's already
funny nothing she's already done a lot
of adapting for me if you don't cut my
wage if you say that but boom that's
what I understood when I really got to
grips with it that actually she she done
a lot of my work for me already excuse a
sorry kerala did you get to see any of
the first movie to begin your work yeah
yeah no I had to yeah yeah I'm not gonna
tell you what homes no it's of
brilliance really good but you can't
with it with a book a petition you can't
obviously get everything and have you
already talked to Suzanne about things
that won't make it into the movie
actually reading possibly right now the
first draft it could well pizza um yeah
I mean she's involved a lot and that
will be things when she just knows her
audience brilliantly until say that bit
you just can't cut out because they'll
all go crazy and other will go
this is fun you changes but she really
knows her her her readers ah and she and
because she's been in the film world she
understands about adapting him that the
things have to go and things have to
change so she'd been really I mean she
been fantastic it's interesting what
movie is this movie The Hunger Game is
about a public key to the game policy
makes kind of people's view difference
so it is that like at you say are you
make this feel more timeless but it's
right now I think it's more people kind
of interesting kind of publicity work
more distinct something I don't even
connect to those two things together
yeah well in the war it's kind of notice
about the thing what it is her I mean
it's happening more and more than ever
gets driven driven by internet and the
publicity and people growing up desiring
to be famous for simply for being famous
Robin for being actually any good or
anything um I think yeah I mean I
haven't I hadn't actually noticed the
connection between those two yeah and
the hunger games is a sort of brutal
satyr but you don't even notice it's a
SATA already a because it's so brutal
it's not funny and be because it's such
an extraordinarily strong story that
you're much more worried
for the characters than you are
examining it as a sort of a greater
political satire about about the TV
world and how people have been to be no
manipulate images to to quell a
population if you well that's really
interesting called which I haven't
occurred to me I must be more stupid I
realized thank you I shall now use that
from now on main reason why private
bright films Thank You anniversary 15
boys are there any elements of salmon
fishing that you think are it can be
more prone to getting lost on kind of
American audiences that vary quite as
familiar I haven't I haven't seen a play
with American audience yet um Hume is a
really funny thing is that some some
jokes just work one side of the Atlantic
and they don't the other but I won't I
found over the other they balance each
other out and some drugs that don't work
in Britain or all alike along this is
love something's that I've written in
bridge stir in my english version aren't
even supposed to be funny can't big
laughs in America and vice versa so in
the end if there's a if there enough
jokes it'll balance itself out um but I
think I think I mean humor just does
play differently across across the
Atlantic but I haven't seen you so i
don't know i don't know how it plays
anything else you working on miss
Kristin Scott Thomas funny oh good this
training I was in you had laughing like
the whole time yes perfect yeah that's
right was it was it your decision or
losses to do the multi split screen
where she's in every single box that was
last time yeah no it's me it lasted on
skype you couldn't understand that
anything
it was slumdog you went to India to
immerse yourself an environment did you
do anything like that for this I learned
how to fly fish which was an amazing
thing to do um which I thought was
really important to get myself in the
head of the shelter ready and what
because I in my head fishing was all
gear and tackle and floats and rods and
engagements of stuff I never looked very
relaxing to me and then when I went
fly-fishing I understood why it become
as a sort of metaphor for for deep
thinking and calm and so far almost of a
faith in itself because it's so simple
it's just a very bendy rod in a bit of
nylon and a fly and that's eat there is
no more gear and you just have to over
there again lets out a bit more line and
you have to be I mean if you're good at
it which I certainly am nor you have to
think like the fish you have to predict
exactly what it's going to be the more
turn exactly when it's going to come up
and take a bite because you actually
have to snatch the rod back before the
fish is closes map I mean it sounds
impossible to do and any way of doing is
by going into a sort of zen-like state
where you just know when to snaps the
rod back and it happens before you've
even seen the fish like the thought of
the fish coming and just know so I got
nowhere near obviously but the really
good people it is watching watching a
really really good fly fisherman is an
incredibly beautiful thing because the
accuracy and the kind of foresight they
have it's very beautiful to watch did
you catch wrong do you know what I did
but only because it was the week of the
mayfly I don't know if you knowing about
fishing which I didn't for the week that
may fight is like it's like an open all
hours buffet fish it is these incredibly
tasty fish that the hatch for like 10
days in May
and the fish just go crazy it's like eat
as much as you can so it's really really
is it sketchy fishing that week and I
did catch fish but never since so you
didn't travel Yemen no unfortunately not
i would love to go i spent a long time
in jordan over the years um so I know
that sort of people and sort of place
quite well um I had a very clearly in my
head no I really wish we could have
filmed into in the Yemen but it became
very unsafe very quickly which one my
starts was acting but wasn't mentioning
that it over though couple years we took
in development it suddenly became as of
al-qaeda hop it so sad you together ah
apart from catching fire the only
obstacle I'm writing adapting full monty
for stage now we're deep in a recession
see mother at times brave back was it
already a media it was musical yeah but
it was setting Buffalo and was quite a
free annotation how dare they completely
unacceptable so I'm setting it back in
Sheffield and it's gonna stop it's
torture are you working with a lyricist
in musician no it's not going to be
musical it's gonna be a straight play
are there any filmmakers that you would
help would adapt one of your screenplays
or indirectly on your screen plays in
the teacher well I'm talking with Danny
a moment about something else he's some
he's extraordinary llantwit and that
really fantastically creative time 127
hours and some ugly now so hope fingers
crossed that will be doing something
else to get any finally surfaces from
the Olympic Games yeah an examinee
witches
extra fee extraordinary undertaking
mother sentiment but what's your process
is a writer get a set schedule 925 you
do some work no I wish no I didn't seem
to work it's some it's it's a mess I
don't maybe think you should draw this
damage I should make up something better
yes I wake of the six and work for eight
hours and break for black coffin Buffalo
GT no I just just work and work and work
and it dad it's not until it gets done
and sometimes it's six in the morning
sometimes late at night I've got two
kids here not the least be interested in
my screen writing career and then I
interrupt operations at all times and
that's fine what I always do is a goat
and wet on my own for the first 10 days
to weeks and completely immerse myself
him in the work and after that any
amount of interruptions and phone calls
and get some stuff is fine but for about
two weeks I need to literally not talk
to you uh and that's really most
important work gets done without that
work what say you should have project
it's you you discover the book and you
know the this I need to write an
application and get options or in a
summer ask you how we have option
facebook so could you like that
occasional hahaha sometimes yeah or
sometimes I read a book and just get
completely captured by it um it's what
he sort of depends it goes all different
also wise really i think i'm working on
the moment adapting it's called sharp
teeth and that's a that's a poem it's an
epic poem set in Los Angeles
um and I it just completely captured me
and it makes no sense to try and adapt
an epic poem into a screen paper okay
good shot anyway just because it's a lot
of work it'sit's years of your life
getting a film off the ground so it has
to be something that really really
captures your imagination sometimes or
something somebody brings to me or
something I fine but they're just very